He's looking at the microphone with awe, just like his father, a natural-born podcaster. He's just drawn to the microphone. You drop down into Codex, boom. In fact, when I installed the Macchi for the first time on my workstation, I've got like two different GPUs, one on the motherboard, which is like a really old Pascal P620 GPU, and then I've got a Quadro RTX, which is still pretty old. It's like a Turing GPU. It got confused somehow, tried to hook up to the QuadroRT.
TX 8,000, and then, like, ended up just like the GUI wouldn't open. So you're in TTI land, which is, like, honestly, when you're dealing with Nvidia drivers, if you've been doing this for the last decade, it's a normal thing. But guess what? Omachi has Codex built in from scratch. You drop down into codex. It took me, like, a couple minutes to realize I could do that. And then it's got three different sign-in methods.
Even though I'm in, like, TTY land, I don't need a browser. You can sign in from another device. I sign it from the other device. And then, boom, I got codex. I've got some driver issues solved for me. I was thinking about... Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 306, recorded on September 30th, 2026. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce.
We chat about Omachi, Linux versus Windows, Codex, and more. So you're on, you're on childcare today? No, no, because of the recording. I guess I should talk into this if we're going to release this part of it. Seeing as we're doing this recording, I told Shima, I could take this. a baby for 10 minutes because he was being pretty fussy downstairs. Would you like to say anything to all the podcast people? He's looking at the microphone with awe, just like his father, a natural-born podcaster.
He's just drawn to the microphone. I think he's probably actually mesmerized by the four monitors and AI's running in a couple of them. We got audacity running in one. You know, I've always been a one monitor. I've got to tell you. And the reason is sometimes I've been like a one big monitor, but it's just like focus. Like I'm an easily distracted person.
I can't have like four monitors with all this stuff on it. Now sometimes I am like, okay, like I am switching between windows a lot. But it's just, it's just too, too much, too much for me. So like right now, you just have the teams running an audacity in the background though. That is correct. Yes. Yeah. See like that, if you had a second monitor.
You know the thing where I want. I know. I know. But if you had a second monitor. you could make sure that the waves, like the audio waves, if something happens to your mic, you're not going to know. So I do have, the one monitor that I have, like for my desk is a really big monitor, but I never work from the desk anymore. I only work from the laptop. I did finally, I did finally get a new laptop. You know, this last laptop that I got, I got in 2017, right around when I joined Invidia. And I've been waiting three years for Invidia to launch the RTX Spark laptops.
I was going to say, weren't you waiting for a special laptop? Well, I kept saying, I kept saying, you know, I'll just wait, like, oh, it's maybe delayed. It'll come out soon. You know, I'll get an early access one. But then it became clear. So they're coming out this fall, but the thing is that I have to have a laptop that has a 5G Y-WAN chip in it. Because if I'm at a conference or an event or something, I, like, other people would be like, oh, like, I'm having trouble getting on the Wi-Fi or whatnot. I never have that problem.
I have an internal broadband card, like wireless broadband card in my laptop. and I just have international data everywhere, so I just open up the laptop, and it connects, and it works. And that's the most important thing for me. So it became clear to me that probably the first generation of the RTS Spark laptops, it's unlikely to have one that will have the 5G card because it's pretty rare for laptops to have 5G cards. So I broke down, and I bought an HPZ book,
which has, wait for it, an AMD CPU and an AMD GPU. Whoa. This is a work laptop? No, no, no. This is a personal laptop. I've always done bringing my device. Oh, I was going to say, you can't even buy a work laptop with AMD hardware in it. Isn't that right? Also, by the way, you can't tell from the video, but the way my camera's oriented and he's looking at the rightmost monitor, he was like staring at you the entire time. I'm not sure if it's the head of hair. Oh, he's about to cry. Do you want to cry into the mic? All right. Thanks for being on the podcast, buddy. We'll go give you to mom. How's that sound? All right. He says, that sounds good. I'm done with this thing.
I'll be back in a second, then you can continue your HP. One moment. All right, we're back. Babyless. Well, the baby's still in the background, but we were talking about this laptop. I had, we've talked before about the start of my career is kind of an interesting start of my career because I did this drop out of college thing. But there's another aspect in the beginning of my career, which has colored my perspective on programming,
which is I started programming and almost immediately was thrown into an H-G, PC environment. So from the start, I was working on concurrent and distributed systems, and specifically in high-performance computing. And, you know, in high-performance computing, you don't do that on your laptop. You connect to somebody else's computer somewhere. And this is colored so much of my experience as a developer. I've largely never used IDs, not necessarily because I think that IDs are bad, but if I'm connecting to insert some supercomputer here. You know, that IDE doesn't run on the supercomputer. Maybe there's some way that I can connect it to the supercomputer today. But let me tell you, in 2011, when I started programming,
there were not really IDEs that had great support for working remotely on some other machine. And the supercomputers back then and also today, you know, they have pretty bare set of hardware and pretty bare set of software installed. And, you know, it can be a pain. You don't have root access on these machines. It's not your machine. It's somebody else's machine that you're running on. So there's certain stuff that you can't install, et cetera.
So I, you know, did almost all my development in VIM. And the reason was just VIM is very easy to go and build and install and run yourself. And the build part is actually important, too, because sometimes I would work on some supercomputer that was some funky architecture where there wouldn't be a pre-built binary that I could go and pull. or if there was a pre-built binary package, it wasn't necessarily a package that I could install because back in the day, maybe there'd be a Debian package for something, but again, I wasn't a root user. This was in the age before containers. I had to use these weird HPC package management
systems, which would have a very select set of packages. But anyways, I got used to sort of working in this environment, in particular where I had very few developer tools available to me reliably because on any given day I might be working on some new or different cluster than I was a month ago and where I'm not working on my laptop. And so like, you know, earlier on in my career, yeah, I did have some like beefy laptops and sometimes I would do work developed like locally. But over time, it just increasingly became like my laptop was simply a thin client to some supercomputer somewhere. And there were a lot of benefits to this. One, like if I started doing something like a compilation, or some task, like, and I needed to go somewhere.
I could just close my laptop. And, like, you know, the thing would still be happening somewhere on somebody's supercomputer. And I feel like when the agentic era started, this gave me, like, a very different perspective than everyone else. I think, like, a lot of people at the start of the agentic era were running agents, like, locally on their laptops, because that's where a lot of developers do their built. I never did that because, like, that is, like, a very foreign idea to me. Why would I ever want to run something in my laptop?
And also my laptop's like this weak, pathetic computer. And so I just from the start always ran my agents fully in, you know, some cloud environment in VMs or sandboxes, which is now just a fancy word for VMs. My apologies to the sandbox community. But, I mean, you know it's true. Anyways. So it was never a priority for me how good my laptop was. And I have this like this think pad.
it's the Lenovo Anniversary Edition 25, and it has the classic think pad, keyboard, track pad, and the little nub mouse in the center. And that's like the keyboard that I love that I, you know, used from my like early days. And so I was like, I'm just going to stick with this thing. Even when I bought it, it was not the world's most powerful, like, laptop. But I didn't care because it had the human interface, the like physical interface that I liked. I already, this Z book, the track pad, I'm already like, oh, my gosh. God, I can't stand this thing.
Like, there's no button to right-click. I have to just click on the bottom right of the thing. Like, I want a physical button. But anyway. So the thing that ultimately, like, killed it from me. Well, this laptop's been on its last. One, the microphone's kind of been dying. And then two, I use whisperflow to do text to speech.
But whisper flow seems to be having some issue with the microphone. So if I have whisper flow running, sometimes, like, the microphone driver just completely crashes or like something happens where like I'll be in the middle of a of a call like this call and then suddenly my microphone will just completely go out. And then I did start running some agent tasks locally, like in particular like things like computer use where I wanted to have access to my browser or something where like I needed it to like set up something or debug a problem on my laptop. I would run it. I would run an agent for that. And what I quickly ran into was like this thing just is not powerful enough to even run the Codex desktop app.
Because this is like a two-core laptop. I did upgrade it some number of years ago to 64 gigs of memory, which is a thing you used to be able to do on laptops. You used to be able to buy new memory and put it into the laptops because everything was modular, but now they're not. Now it's all, I mean, the Z-book actually that I got actually did have configurable memory, but not all of them do. Anyways, that's my old man tirade about my old laptop.
The old laptop also, like, in addition to like the microphone dying, and now like Windows is like not really stable on it anymore. And it's a Windows 10 laptop because it does not meet the hardware requirements to upgrade to Windows 11. There's an issue. And like Windows Explorer crashes a lot and other apps crash a lot and Chrome freezes up a lot. And it is now like more recently, it has started to develop physical ailments. Like there are parts of it that are like literally falling off. Like there's a corner that's chipped now. There's parts where like the plastic is wearing through.
This thing has seen a lot and it is time for it to be retired. So soon the new laptop will be fully onboarded. Ah, and I shall start over. A fantastic opportunity to get rid of Windows and start fresh, not just from any Linux distribution, which, oh boy, oh boy, are we going to lose some listeners here, folks? You know, because I messaged you about this leading up to setting up this recording. And I took a break last week because I was in the second week of my Pat leave. And I could have set up a recording, but honestly, I was pretty tired.
And I was like, you know what? I deserve a break. We're just going to take a week off. I'm going to record one of my seven to ten minute podcasts and just refer people to other podcasts. And I went ahead and referred people to a bunch of podcasts. One of them, did you listen to the Jensen interview with Ezra Klein or did that cross your radar? I've seen that. I've seen people complaining about that on Twitter.
Yeah, he upset a lot of people. A lot of people are upset that he said long divisions no longer required. And maybe we should do a whole episode dedicated to reviewing our thought. The point that I'm trying to get to here has nothing to do with Jensen. It was that I mentioned DHH, who is a, I don't even know his full name, David, 2Hs. And he's a Ruby guy. And he was on Lex Friedman and he had a five-hour podcast. And then more recently, I didn't mention this last week.
He gave a keynote at Rails World, which apparently, there's a whole controversy behind that as well because he was not invited one year to speak at RailsConf and then that and then he like boycotted that set up Rails World as like a competing conference and then RailsConf ended up like folding because it couldn't financially survive anyways apparently there's a whole lot of drama behind this guy you know what we need to put that to the side and I know we've lost listeners before because we mentioned Elon and then people get upset because you listen folks I don't endorse any of his political of beliefs we We accept all people here.
We are equal opportunity, equal everything. We love everybody. You know, let's all just get along. That being said, let's set aside this guy's political things. What he's doing right now, it's fantastic. Apparently there's this stop-omachi.com site, and you shouldn't do it. But listen, folks, it's like when I used to eat at Chick-fil-A. You know, Chick-fil-A had some views I didn't agree with.
But they also had the best fried chicken sandwich out there, and it wasn't close. You're going to get canceled, Connor. You're going to be canceled. You're going to end up in, like, tomorrow you're going to be going to be going to be like, oh, I can't. None of this is usable. It is usable. It is usable. Is it?
I mean, I'm not, okay, here's my point. I'm happy to switch to another fried chicken sandwich, which I did. In Toronto, there's a boutique institution called Tokyo Fried Chicken. I always get my, I live in a different place now, so I'm not close to that. But when I was downtown, I would always order there. I never went to Chick-fil-A. But at the time, there was a time when I lived in the States, it was the best fried chicken sandwich I knew. about and I would go there knowing that I didn't agree with the beliefs of the management,
but it was still the best fried chicken sandwich. I'm not going to not eat the best fried chicken sandwich if the next step down is so much worse. And that's what Omachi is, folks. It's an agentic AI first operating system. I'm running it right now. It's technically Arch. Who cares though? And it has like codex and quad code, everything built into it. You can change anything about the computer. You don't like something? You just ask, just ask it to be changed. I have a completely configured, custom configured computer now. that different from what I have, which is I just install Windows 11 and then the Codex desktop app and then to set up anything in the computer, I just whisper flow into Codex and tell it to do the
thing that I want. Does that work as seamlessly and as integrated when it's like built from scratch? Can you go and like completely destroy like the file explorer and replace it with like some other thing? Probably not, but I don't feel like I need to. Listen, I'll tell you that. I mean, I'm not saying you want to replace the file explorer but i'm just saying like everything one of my primary is possible now one of my primary functions like the things that i use most one is like a terminal to some other computer i can do that anywhere then like powerpoint and excel and google chrome you can do google chrome anywhere but but powerpoint and excel you're going to have the best experience on windows and one of the things with powerpoint is i often need to plug my laptop into
somebody's projector somewhere to project something. And I've never seen people struggle as much to do that with Windows as they have with things that are not Windows. And I mean, you know... You got a problem in the future? You drop down to Codex and say, fix my connection issue. That's exactly what I did with my media laptop,
except I wasn't on Omachi at that point. I'm still on Ubuntu downstairs. But like, for whatever... Because I'm running Ubuntu on like a MacBook Pro from 2012. So it's got a bunch of like kernel issues and whatnot. and connecting to the PC from like the sources on the TV was always so finicky. And then I was like, wait a second. I have codex here.
And so I said codex, like figure out what's wrong. I just want when I, when I click PC, I always want it. And it found a bunch of issues. And so now whenever I restart the computer, my BashRC file runs like a little script that does some like HDMI audio like codec resetting. And it works perfectly now. So like if you ever add a, here's a challenge. If you're ever on Linux in the future trying to connect to some.
projector, you drop down into Codex, boom. Codex solves that. In fact, when I installed the Machi for the first time on my workstation, I've got like two different GPUs, one on the motherboard, which is like a really old Pascal P620 GPU, and then I've got a Quadro RTX, which is still pretty old. It's like a TURRTX, it got confused somehow, tried to hook up to the Quadro RTX 8,000, and then like ended up just like the GUI wouldn't open. So you're in TTILAND, which is like, honestly, when you're dealing with Invidia
drivers, if you've been doing this for the last decade, it's a normal thing, but guess what? Omachi has codex built in from scratch. You drop down into codex. It took me like a couple minutes to realize I could do that. And then it's got three different sign-in methods. Even though I'm in like TTILand, I don't need a browser. You can sign in from another device. I sign it from the other device.
And then boom, I got codex. I said codex. I've got some driver issues solved it for. I was thinking about trying, you know, I used to run only Linux. I mean, I famously, you know, back in the day was running Linux on my map. Not that famous. Well, I was the first person to compile the Linux current. with LVM, just saying.
My first claim to frame, at some point it just got to be like, you know, too much work. And I just sort of, I did dual boots for a while, and then I just found myself spending on my time in the Windows machine. I have thought, I did think recently about whether I can go to Linux. And one of my questions there was like, what's the experience of running PowerPoint and wine? And it's apparently not, not great. Bro, and also, too, PowerPoint's dead.
Powerpoint's dead. What are you doing? You get codex to write all your slide decks. My first presentation that I gave post the big jump, which was like tail end of November in 2025, happened to be in December. I was speaking at conference down in Australia. And I didn't even realize. Like, nobody was talking about how good the jump was.
And I was just like, I started off with the title slide, with the Matrix Rain. And then I was like, oh, I'll add an about me. And then I was like, wait a sec. This is so good. Like, can't I keep going? You don't need PowerPoint. I will give you a piece of career advice that your bot manager gave me, which is, you know, I was, back in the day, I used to use my own templates that was not the Nvidia PowerPoint
template. I still kind of do, but back in the day, he asked me, hey, can you use the Nvidia PowerPoint template? Because that makes it easier for other people to incorporate your stuff into their slides. And the sort of broader lesson there is that sometimes you shouldn't necessarily use the best tool for yourself personally. Sometimes you have to think about what is the ecosystem around you, the ecosystem of the organization that you are in. And like at NVIDIA, the one, the majority of our existing like content is PowerPoint documents, Google documents, you know, Microsoft Word, et cetera. That's the majority of existing content. And so if I need to, like, a lot of times that I'm making a slide deck or a presentation or
something, 80% of it is stuff that I've already have from other decks that I'm just piecing together. And if I had to go and move to a completely new framework, that would be harder to do. But then also, I have to collaborate with other people, and I got to share things with other people. And those other people need to be able to use them. And we all have to agree upon a common format, a common, like, you know, unit of exchange. And at Nvidia, that is PowerPoint. I mean, some people use, like, Google slides. But that's actually fairly rare. And there's all sorts of issues when people use Google slides. So, yeah, actually, when you, when you mentioned this, I was thinking at one point I did do something in Google slides. And my manager was like, well, can you turn this into PowerPoint?
Like, I need to copy it into my slide deck. And I was like, oh, yeah, fair point. So you are not without a solid point. I still don't think PowerPoints. And also, too, you give more, you do more presentations and like training and stuff. Like probably by a fact at this point, like, ever since I switched to research, factor of five, maybe an order of magnitude, factor of 10. So that's probably more, like, honestly, I've spoken at one conference this year. And then the one before that was the one back in December. So my conferencing has taken a precipitous decline, as opposed to you. You've been traveling the world all year.
But anyways, give a thought. Give it a shot, buddy. Watch the DHS World. I was thinking about it with the new laptop. I was thinking about trying Linux, going back to Linux. And if it's a new laptop, apparently, like for me, installing it on my workstation, took, I think, two minutes. And for my work laptop, it took three and a half.
but they're claiming that like for speedy machines it's less than a minute to install like you flash the USB and it installs in less than a minute. So you mean it's not even going to cost you that much time, you know? And it's beautiful. It's beautiful. I'm not sure if you've ever used a tiling window system. It is the reality is that a good chunk of what I do on Windows is Windows would be a lot less usable for me if not for WSL, especially these days. So it's sort of like it's a question of whether I run Windows where I'm doing a lot of stuff in WSL or whether I well in Linux, where I'm doing a lot of stuff in a Windows VM.
And that's the thing is if you're in WSL or WSL2, you know, I set my brother-in-law, he had Super GROC and he saw some of the stuff I was doing. And I was like, let me just, because I was, it would have been easier for me to just, like, teach a man to fish. So I basically took his laptop, set up WSL2, set up Super GROC. And, like, I ran into some issues because you do have access to the whole file system from there, but you kind of have to, like, it's like a, what do you call it, like a crab trap.
You got to go like outside and then around to get to the rest of the ocean. The point being that it is possible, but a couple times when I was asking it to like make changes to its kind of environment, it would reset every single time. He like went in and out of GRO and I was like, yeah, this is just an issue you're going to have to live with with WSL2. Whereas if you're on native Linux, regardless of your distro, you're never going to have to have that issue, right? Yeah.
Well, maybe the title of this episode will be, Will Bryce switch to Linux? The biggest problem is what do I do about all my. existing PowerPoint decks that I don't really have a realistic way to like interact with from Linux other than maybe a VM but then that's a pain if I have to like you know screen share yeah it's a huge problem because the PowerPoint's web powerpoint doesn't work very well people in the comments yeah I know about Microsoft 365 the web app is not the same experience as it's not it's not as good and things and it's not the same rendering engines and things do not render the same. One of the beautiful things, though, it does seem that for whatever reason on
Omachi, it works slightly better. There was one issue that I always had with the online Microsoft PowerPoint color picker. It like couldn't get the color picker of the screen correct. It was always off. And so if anyone pays attention real close attention to the array cast thumbnails pre-episode 130 on YouTube, you'll see that there's like two slightly different shades of blue because the color picker doesn't work, but on Omachi, works seamlessly, perfectly. I don't know why Arch is better than Ubuntu, I think it was on 2404,
whatever the latest LPS was. I'm a Debbie in person. It would be, it's, yeah, I'm a Debian person. I don't know that I want to go learn Arch. Well, that's the thing. You don't even need to learn Arch. You just ask codex everything, you know? I'm an old man, Connor.
I'm an old man. All right, should we bundle, because I had a couple topics I wanted to talk about. Should we bundle those in to this episode because we're at the 27 minute mark? we could rapid fire them and then all right we're keeping it well people don't know what we cut but we cut that part yeah or we 10x and made me sound like a chipmunk anyways so i mentioned the dh8 stuff i mentioned the agentic OS and oh we'll leave my AI apps for later i'll just i'll just show
you bryce that thanks to being inspired by dhhhh you can now see basically the bottom row of my phone they're all the same icon we've got pod god stock god fam god baby god home god and healy chubb. We are replacing all of these irritating ad-ridden apps with, and let's go, look at this, look at this, buddy. This is my stock app, which is, it's fine. What's that? Conner now has investments?
I remember pre-dad Conner where he's like, it's all just funny money, it's all just going to be in video. I'm just going to get rid of. It is all still in video. I don't have investments. I just like looking at the prices of other companies. I still only own one stock folks. Diversification as, was it Mark Twain,
or some famous person said, maybe Warren Buffett, It's for people that don't know what they're doing. And let me tell you, folks, I know what I'm doing. But you can see on this second page, it's a sexy version of the top market cap companies. It's got little red letters as the prices change. It's just absolutely beautiful, folks. Anyways, we're slowly, you can do everything now. You got some irritating app?
Done. It's gone. And let me tell you, I'll tell you about Home God. It's my smart home app. It's amazing. Anyways, we're taking over. New operating system. One thing that's very interesting is you are.
Like, me on the consumer and, like, personal side, I am much more conservative with what I will use AI to do. Whereas on the work side, I am, like, very, like, over leveraged. Maybe, I mean, we're probably at a similar scale there. But, like, on the home side, I'm a lot more conservative. Like, I'm not, I don't feel the need. There's not that many things where I have the need to use at home. I do use it now for some of my travel planning and, like, tracking things like that. I feel like you are far more on that side of it.
I can't think of like a thing where I'd be like, oh, I want like my own version of this app. Like this existing app like isn't it good enough for me? I can't, I don't have a version of that. You think of that, but that's, I'm trying to figure out the exact. I'm sure that there are things. I just haven't. It's just that like I don't feel like, I don't feel like I have time.
You know, it's actually actually an interesting like aspect of my work life balance where I've never understood people who have time for like side coding projects. You're not coding anymore. You're just directing. No, no, I know. I get that. But like, like even in the era before, I never, like, you did more like, you know, fun projects on the side.
You've always done more like stuff on the side that's like fun or exciting. Me, almost all of my coding has almost all of my like software engineering work has been like exclusively on like my primary work mission or like slightly adjacent like work. missions and that I always feel like I have no time for anything other than like the three or four major work things there on my plate and like I guess can't imagine how people would have the time like I can't I can't envision how you have the time even with AI to build something like podcast well I've been admittedly I mentioned in last week's episode I've started the release process but like you have to get a certain kind of number and then Google's got to review it I thought it was like you could
just throw an app. Like, I thought Flappy Bird, I just assume it went on the play store like a day after it was finished. It takes weeks. And so I don't think it's going to be out until October. But I've been working on PodGod since February, like since late January. And I think I've really let perfection be the enemy of good or like even great because like my podcast player is better than every other podcast player out there. But it still has bugs here and there. And I feel like because it's completely like developed agentically, like I'm going to get so much criticism for like, oh, you see, it doesn't work. And it's like, well, no, all the other ones don't fricking work too or, like, don't have
the features that I want. Anyway, so it has taken months, but like now, putting up a simple stock god, you know, track a few things and, like, you know, that takes like 20 minutes, you know, it doesn't take that much time. And also, it takes 20 minutes for the AI. It takes, like, 30 seconds for me to draft the prompt and then another four minutes of like, no, no, no, I want square logos. I want center.
I want spacing. Anyway, so I, no, no, it's not about time. It's that if I, if I would, if I had that. time, I would have spent that time on a new work project, not on something for me. Oh, yeah, maybe fair enough. But that's like, that comes into like a intrinsic, extrinsic, like, where do you get your purpose in life? That's what I'm getting at.
It's like, for me, like, I never used to think of myself as a workaholic. But I think that is one of the signs that I am a workaholic. Yeah, I'm like a work slash side projectaholic. Yeah. I'm not, like, I have never, like, maybe early on in my. career, I had a few hobby projects, like the Linux kernel thing. But very quickly, it became like, like, I've never really had, like, hobbyist programming projects since then. It's all just been whatever my main focus is. And that if I had spare cycles, maybe I would take on a new, like,
work project. Yeah. I don't know what this is about. Yeah, that's just like what, whatever charges your wheel or whatever. Anyway, the last, the last two things I was going to mention, one of them is in our updated ADSP thepodcast.com website. We've got new stats that you can go and check out. But one of the things, I sent you the important takeaway was by year percentage of episodes that have guests. And since 20, we peaked at 2023 with 62%, 2024 was 42%, 2025 was 37.
And in 2026, folks, we're down to 23%. Really? And so this episode and probably the next episode that we're going to release a little bit later will be hopefully for Bryce and the last two, just us, well maybe do one other. But I want to get that. I want to see if we can get above 37%.
Because admittedly, we've gotten feedback at our annual reviews where people like the interviews. And I don't know why I guess we've just been having too much fun chatting about AI. And we know that we're both excited about AI. And so it's always a risk. To be fair, we've also both had a lot going on. And it like requires more thinking ahead of time in scheduling and planning instead of us just like, oh, we got to record. Let's hop on at 4 p.m. on a Thursday. But I totally, I am all for more guests.
Yes. And, yeah, I mean, I love doing guest episodes. I think the audience loves doing guest episodes. I always learn something in guest episodes. I feel like, I guess I always learn something talking to Connor anyways. But like I learn, I both learned something and like become closer with some new friend. So I love it. So yeah, we were even going to have a guest today, but they have not replied.
Admittedly, we sent them an email two days ago. So not. huge surprise. And then the last thing I'll mention to round out this episode is that a couple times over the last little bit, I've mentioned books. When we were talking to Mark Serafin back in July, which only released like a couple weeks ago because of the backlog that we were building up due to the kid being on the way. He recommended a bunch of books. And I since then have created an AI-Fi ranking for myself personally. I'm working through a ton of stuff. Right now, I just finished Neuromancer and I'm like through five of the eight or nine murder bot books,
Okay, the first one was pretty good. Neuromancer hot take was terrible. But anyways, if people are interested and they have recommendations outside of the books that I've already read, I already got a couple via Twitter DMs and the GitHub discussions. Go check out that link and feel free to recommend shows or books. That concludes, I think this is going to be episode 306. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a
get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.